-Good luck, bud.
-Alright.
♪♪
Wheel of Musical Impressions!
Here we go.
-Oh, come on!
-♪ Wheel of Musical
Impressions ♪
♪ Wheel of Musical
-Alright, Jay Pharoah,
you're gonna get a singer, okay?
And then you're gonna have to
sing a song
while doing an impression
of them.
Let's see what you get.
Since you're good at
impressions, this is perfect.
[ Laughs ] I just saw
something really fun.
Ooh!
-Oh, yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes! Yes!
-[ Laughs ] That is great.
-Alright.
-You have Jay-Z rapping
"Mary Had a Little Lamb."
[ Laughter ]
I don't -- Do you know
how to do -- What --
-We got to hip-hop it out,
I guess, Jay.
Let's figure it out, Jay.
-Okay.
-What do you think?
-I don't know.
I'm pretty -- I'm pretty
nervous, Jimmy.
I don't know.
-Try --
-You got this. Please.
-Try this over here.
-I don't know.
-Come on, Jay.
Come on, Jay!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Indistinct ]
[ Hip-hop beat plays ]
-♪ Shyeah, oh! ♪
♪ Uh-uh uh-uh uh-uh, shyeah ♪
♪ Everybody put your hands up ♪
♪ Shyeah, put your hands up ♪
♪ Shyeah, shyeah ♪
♪ Mary had a little lamb ♪
♪ Its fleece was white as snow ♪
♪ Shyeah, shyeah ♪
♪ And everywhere
that child went ♪
♪ That lamb was sure to go ♪
♪ Uh-uh uh-uh-uh ♪
-[ Laughing ]
-♪ He followed her
to school one day ♪
♪ Broke the teacher's rule ♪
♪ What a time did they have
that day at school ♪
♪ Tisket, a-tasket,
a green and yellow basket ♪
♪ Sent a letter to my baby,
on the way I passed it ♪
♪ Mary had a little lamb,
its fleece was white as snow ♪
♪ And everywhere
that child went ♪
♪ That lamb was sure to go ♪
♪ Oh, shyeah ♪
♪ Uh-uh uh-uh uh-uh ♪
♪ That was -- uh-uh uh-uh ♪
♪ Shyeah ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You gotta poke your chest out.
-That is a standing ovation.
-♪ Shyeah ♪
-That is a standing --
That is a standing ovation
for you!
-Shyeah. Well, you know.
-Yeah!
-You know, Jimmy.
-What?!
-Jimmy, I haven't felt this way
since I was in,
you know, Madison Square
for the first time, you know.
-Thank you, Jay.
-Yeah.
-By the way, our very own
Jade Novah from the Jam Band
does a pretty awesome Beyoncé.
-Oh, can I say this?
She's got the best Beyoncé
in the world.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on, do it. Come on.
-Oh, yes!
-Come on!
-Now, first of all,
excuse me, Jimmy.
-Beyoncé.
-Now, I have some beef with you,
Jay, first of all.
How you gonna talk
about Mary's lamb
when clearly you know
my lamb is king? [ Laughs ]
-Shyeah.
-Okay.
So I'mma tell y'all
about Yoncé's lamb.
Y'all ready for this?
You ready, Jay?
-Shyeah.
-Yeah.
♪ Beyoncé had a little lamb ♪
♪ And that lamb was flawless ♪
-Uh-huh.
-♪ Beyoncé up on
"That's My Jam" ♪
♪ Yeah, I'm takin' all this ♪
-Oh!
-♪ So the next time you talk
about Mary's lamb ♪
♪ Make sure you let them know ♪
-Shyeah.
-♪ That anywhere that Yoncé go ♪
♪ Everybody follow ♪
-♪ Shyeah ♪
-Oh, my God!
-It's so lovely.
-Thank you so much.
-Shyeah.
-Thank y'all.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Shyeah.
Shout-out to the Beyhive.